good morning so I'm bill Wagner we're
going to be looking at pattern matching
in c-sharp 7:00 this morning so most
important things in this slide is how to
reach me via email or Twitter if you
have any questions after this talk go
ahead and reach out there I will post
both the slides and the demos on my
github repository later I will announce
it on the Twitter handle okay so we're
going to talk a little bit about the
languages and where C sharp is going and
C sharp seven primarily the investments
are evolving for modern patterns
distributed applications
so today commence C sharp first came out
as a language roughly 2000 we wrote
desktop applications maybe client server
maybe websites mostly static pages going
down and forms it's very different than
the program for writing today we're
writing small services that run on
distributed machines that leads to a
different decomposition of problems
objects aren't necessarily the right way
to solve every problem we're more often
separating data for transit from the
algorithms that operate on that data
that's probably the big theme of c-sharp
7 is things like tuples pattern matching
and others for anyone who's in
Kathleen's talk so you have a good
overview of all of those now one of the
things that we really liked as working
with the c-sharp team is c-sharp is one
of the most popular technologies out
there according to the Stack Overflow
survey toward the end of 2016 and the
set gets a little smaller if we look at
the most loved technologies c-sharp is
one of a very small set of languages on
both of those lists so it's used by a
really really large number of developers
and by and large the developers that use
c-sharp like it so it's an important
goal for us is to keep that and
hopefully move up on both of those
f-sharp of course has a little more love
which is nice they're good people
okay so let's look at some of the big
big things as when going on in c-sharp
instead of running on Windows we now run
everywhere just to show that we do still
have support for Windows today's demos
are on windows I talked Wednesday was
all on a Mac so we do still support
Windows you know that net is the system
component more and more with dotnet core
you could deploy dotnet with your
application it's going to make side by
side a little bit easier as we get a
little bit more investments there it's
going to make it easier for things like
running and docker containers and so on
can deploy something that's totally
self-contained running out of VM and the
CLR we're now also making investments
into compiling c-sharp through dotnet
native into native code on various
platforms so you'll be actually running
native code that's started to see sure
the compilers have open ap is the
Roselyn API if you're here last year I
gave a talk on building rosin Roselyn
analyzers there's been further
investments in that so you can continue
to do open compiler api's and add your
own hooks edit in your favorite editor
or Visual Studio once again some of the
demos I did Wednesday weren't vs code
today I'm going to use Visual Studio
proprietary everything is open source so
as I discussed pattern matching too at
the end of the talk I'll show you how to
find this spec for patterns and
investments that will go on beyond
c-sharp 7 as we do more things with
patterns and you can engage in the
discussion there directly on github on
the Rosalind repo okay so let's look at
pattern matching as a definition of what
it means for c-sharp developers in terms
of what you've already done with code
and the kinds of things that we're going
to do the definition I want to use for
pattern matching is that we are going to
test that a value or variable has a
certain shape and extract information
when it does so there's three keys to
that definition in terms of what we're
going to learn about
our matching first we test something
about a variable not necessarily its
type not necessarily its structure in
terms of a normative way c-sharp types
classes have names and so on but we're
going to test something about a variable
has a certain shape certain properties
certain values in those properties and
then we are going to extract information
when it does so once we found what we're
looking for we're going to do something
with that variable now we already do
that but the syntax is a little bit
clumsy for instance this is one of the
some of the code that we're going to
start with if you look this is the kind
of code that we would have to write
today to test what type of an object
comes in there's a lot of if this is
some type and so on and then we move
down and then we'll do a cast because we
figured out what type it is so those are
separate operations we're going to
perform some tests and then we're going
to if that test succeeds then we've got
a block of code that does some work on
that variable it's a little clumsy this
is structured to be somewhat clean my
last two demos I'm going to try to do
pull request for a couple live projects
to change from code that's noticeably
uglier than this into using c-sharp
seven pattern matching so that's going
to be your key here's what we're going
to do is we're going to take this test
wow that we leave is in the wrong spot
there well and test the value and then
bring it back and extract at the same
time in c-sharp seven we're taking some
small steps toward pattern matching
there is a rich vocabulary for patterns
if we look at the spec you'll see a lot
of them laid out c-sharp has three
particular ones that are supported that
are new first of all there's the
consonant pattern which to some degree
is already supported you can test if a
value has a certain variable has a
certain value we're comparing against
the constant well now we can compare and
extract at the same time we have a tight
pattern we are going to test that a
variable is a certain type and we'll
extract into a new variable that type
immediately in one
expression and then there is the null
pattern which is kind of a special case
of the constant pattern but it's
interesting because null doesn't
necessarily have a type so we're going
to support look and look at those three
supported patterns and there are two
statements that work with that there's
been enhancements to the is statement
and there have been enhancements to the
switch statement let's support these
patterns okay so what we're going to get
is we're gonna get is expressions to
test if a variable is a certain type and
the if so we'll extract information from
it
switchin case expressions they can test
the type and extract information from it
and the switch is further enhanced with
a wind conditional so we can test the
type and if the type matches we can
apply further tests that look at
information and properties on that
particular type so let's start exploring
a little bit so here's our first our
main demo I built a console application
that declares several different
variables with some interesting or non
interesting values so I've got a couple
integers so we know that's a struct
actually has values has numbers I've got
a nullable out first one is the null
value or the default value for a
nullable int I have a couple different
numbers there and then we have strength
and put a few interesting cases there
I've got null as a string I have the
empty string I have just a whitespace
string and then just a phrase and then
I've built the structure that's a point
structure up here simple Cartesian
points x and y override the two strings
with prints and things out and then I've
built a few interesting points one that
has at the origin 0 0 3 4 nice little
Pythagorean triangle and 23 and 19 which
are two prime numbers that add up to 42
because that's how we roll
okay and then I've just built an array
of objects that has each one of those in
and we're going to walk through
and convert both this ugly code for is
patterns into using pattern matching and
then we'll do the same thing with the
switch expressions if I run it right now
I'm going to pass in turn each one of
these different variables into these
tests below that say all right is this
an integer is this nullable int is it a
string and is it a point and if so then
I'm going to cast it and then print out
a little information about it so if we
run it we'll find okay so we've started
our is expressions I found and it to
integers 0 and 42 interestingly I found
two more integers 0 and 42
found strings notice that there are
three and I found three points okay
that's all good so a few interesting
things we learned right away from this
code is that it never finds the null
values okay if we look through this it
never finds the null string or the
nullable null int because null will fall
through both of those is tests notice it
doesn't find the null string either
because it is on a null string well it's
null it's not really a string is it so
those tests are already failing and the
final interesting one is notice that
even though I'm testing for a nullable
int I never wrote out that we found a
nullable int everything we found
actually already did the cast and cast
it to an integer so we never actually
found that tight so because of the rules
of how convergence happened this code is
a little bit interesting and already has
some subtle subtle issues with it
depending on what we were trying to do
and finally if we look at the code
itself we can see a couple interesting
little bits of ugliness here if you look
at where I'm testing for an integer or a
nullable int where I'm converting it to
an int and what I'm testing for those
that point which is a structure I have
to use a cast rather than the as
operator right because we can't do is
with value types
until now okay so let's start to rewrite
some of this and use pattern expressions
and what we're going to find is codes
going to get a little shorter it's going
to get a little cleaner and it's not
going to make as many mistakes so first
we want to test and see if it's an end
so what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to say if my object to test is an
int I so I'll do the assignment right
there on the is statement I notice that
now it is okay I can check to see if
it's an nth I'm going to do a assignment
life is good and I'm going to do that
just copy that right line right up here
all good so that one so far is pretty go
great okay so we've got rid of about two
or three lines there let's now we're
going to do the same thing here of my
nullable int
that should work
and I will leave this that's not make
that one so now what's interesting with
nullable ends is that first one that
object to test if I check to see if it
is an integer and assign it that will
work with nullable n that has a value
because I can convert that integer to
can convert d nullable into an INT
directly so let's just go ahead and run
right now
and now we'll see as we get pretty much
the same result as we had before except
that I'm getting builders
I miss my ski oh yes ah right so let's
change that one to J down there there we
go okay cool
alright so we still find convert our
knowable instance cool now what was
interesting is that the only thing
that's really a ting check here that we
find is if that nullable int actually is
null okay so let's check that null
pattern so if object to test is null
and then of course we're not going to
try to do this cast because that would
clearly fail okay and now you see that
we find the nulls both for the knowable
int when it has its default value and we
find the nulls for the strength is the
first one of the strings now points out
that we find a null all right so far so
good
now let's start to expand and really
look at the string and say that you know
there's a few different things that we
can do here that's really fun so we
found a string we found a point well now
let's really start to play and add new
other interesting things that we want to
test for let's say I want to test for an
actual value so up here I'm going to say
if object to test is int we had a 5 up
there if I remember right oh no we are
42 which we can't do with those let's
start adding those in the switch so now
to expand this let's look at our switch
pattern which gives us quite a bit more
interesting things that we can do so
we're used to a switch in general and
that we can put a few things under the
constant pattern well now what we can do
is we're going to be able to switch on
any type so I'm switching on object so
I'm going to build case labels based on
what we find in that object and here's
similar to the is statement that we had
up above I'm going to say if our case
int I and we'll just do the right line
yeah okay so so far we just added that
one particular case I could run through
and now you can see as we start on the
switch expressions we're starting to
find some things with different integers
okay well values are still important so
let's now say I have case int I when I
is 42
and I deleted my opening brace there
accidentally all right cool clothes just
run let's make sure I type the code
correctly yes
found the secret got our zeroes and
final secret so now what's cool here in
the new syntax note that first of all
inside the switch statement each case
block now introduces its own scope for
variables I've got two variables I there
and they are two different variables for
the first switch and for the second okay
so we have that particular feature where
now each one of those blocks in the
newer switch statement is its own scope
even though we don't have braces to kind
of imply it's kind of cool this also
starts to show one of the interesting
things that now happens with case and
switch is that now order matters you can
see I'm now getting red squiggles here
because it's telling me you know what
you're never going to get to that code
because every integer was found in the
case of boss so we now have unreachable
code detected because scale Able's will
be evaluated in the order that they were
they are they appear in the switch
statement with one exception I can write
my default here
and of course I still need a break
by convention we'll probably right that
particular case statement at the bottom
but the compiler plays a little bit of
magic
and I can put it in whatever order I
wanted to be and it will still get
evaluated last okay don't do that that
was really ugly code all right so we've
got that pattern set up so far awesome
all right so now so far we've checked
for integers okay well we could do a
case do our null case
and now suddenly we're going to pick up
the nullable int that has no value the
string that has nothing in it and then
we're still not parsing our strings in
our points yet okay let's start looking
at strengths so we'll start with just
the case string s and now we're going to
write line that we found the string okay
again only a few things that can help us
out we've now found three different
strains that are not null first one is
the empty string second one is a bunch
of whitespace all right well let's add a
string s when a string that is null or
empty
and you see we solve the empty string we
still have our whitespace string in
there okay
well it's easy enough to cope with we'll
add another one immediately following
and say you know instead of null or
empty let's just do nollie whitespace
which I think this is another whitespace
and again now we get to pull those in
and we get things that have different
statements in it all right so now we're
finding whether or not we have an empty
string we're finding just blanks we're
doing those tests and we're putting that
code together and it's noticeably
cleaner than it was before both up here
and down here and then we can add our
case for the points
and we'll find the origin
okay so we can do any kinds of tests
than the object that we find we can call
any expression in their test any value
test any properties do whatever we want
in a one Clause okay all good stuff so
effectively what we've done here again
as we look at how this code looks let's
just evaluate a little bit about the
structure of the code and the kinds of
things that we're doing we've taken this
test to see if the value has something
extract information from it and then do
something with it
we've combined the first two test to see
if a value has certain properties
extract it into a new value and then do
whatever we want with that particular
value okay we've expanded the case
statement so that now case can do to
work on any different kinds of variable
not simply numerix or the string it
cannot work on any type and in addition
to just checking the type we can check
particular values of a type I think I
can also simplify this and just say
they're not in this bill thought that
was there
okay so we have a simpler syntax to do
the test and to put this into our
different work together all right so far
so good
so now let's walk through in a larger
project where we see some real-life code
as to what kind of ugliness happens in
current more imperative tests and let's
apply c-sharp pattern matching to those
so I'm going to open up no to time and I
wish John were here in this talk this
would be fine and the give a little bit
of context to this particular code what
this method does other times a big
project since why we don't use big
projects for demos I get to wait okay
what this particular method does is is
going to try to get a noted information
for a particular culture to figure out
what time zone you're in what culture
you're working with and so on and if we
walk through we can see that it does is
okay so if the provider that came in was
null well we're going to use the current
culture okay so far so good if the
provider is not null well let's see if
it is a culture info object if so I'm
going to call get format info culture
info object get the right information
for the culture that we're working in at
this point in time which is cash - no -
time because you're probably using the
same time zones for different different
tests and then if it is not a current
culture info or a culture info object
it's probably a date-time format info in
which case we're going to create a noted
time format info with the invariant
culture pass that back on and that's
what we use for our time info and if
none of those work what we want to throw
a new argument exception because we
really don't know what's going on and
you probably are using no - time wrong
because it can't be John Skeets bug we
know that
okay so let's change this to C sharp 7
well I've got about three or four
different tests here
then I'm going to check for so let's
just do a switch on provider and the
first one he has is that null and if we
get the case no I'm just going to return
get format info from culture info
current culture okay so I'm combining a
little bit of stuff just to make this a
bit cleaner and that if you look what
will happen in the original code down
below if provider is no I'm going to
sign it to current culture current
culture is a culture info object so the
next test is going to succeed and then
I'm going to drop down into that return
get current info okay so my first
practice is you know now I've got to
read about six or seven lines of code to
make that conversion as to what actually
happens in the case when you pass a null
provider
it's nice clean code but I still have to
do a little bit of analysis to figure
out exactly what's right that new line I
just wrote is really really clear you
pass in null you get the timing flow for
the current culture groovy next one
let's now just say is culture info and
we'll assign to the same variable name
because it's a nice way to do it and
we're still going to return get format
info and now we're going to call that
culture info that connects the variable
it was just assigned hate to make a bug
on chain on stage because I want to
submit this PR and then the last one I'm
going to grab these two comments because
I think that's probably important
and then we're going to have a date-time
format info
and here I'm going to grab that return
statement
and I thought I'd grab the extra no yeah
I did grab the extra one there there we
go I'm getting the red squigglies
because I've left the code below that
read eclairs those same variables and
now I can delete this code and if I
didn't match any of the cases then we're
just going to throw that argument
exception so taking that 15 20 lines of
code that we had to snake through just a
little bit and clean that up just a just
a touch nice well so that's a 1
real-world example of working with
pattern matching to do a few different
type tests and extract that information
in a more clean fashion so let's look at
the second one if anyone was in damien
and david's talk on monday they talked
about building tag helpers and they
talked about building tag helpers
yeah so I'm telling you're going to fail
out me on this one alright fine
I had this happen a few times because
I've got to build it slightly newer than
they have give me this switch to their
branch and let's close that and reopen
it and now we'll migrate that again yes
cool
and as this loads what happens with the
tag helpers you get this tag and the
information that you need may be stored
in a few different ways in a few
different places inside the tag helper
and Damian talked about the particular
code there starts right here at line 45
where we're going to look at this source
which is fugitive the particular
attribute for the source we're going to
try to look at it as a string if that's
null then we're going to walk through
and look at this as an HTML string that
may or may be and if so we're going to
grab its value and if that path is null
still then we're going to do some other
code yeah this looks kind of ugly and
you know it sneaking through a few
different cases there to unwind if the
path is null we're going to start doing
some stuff we're going to try to see if
it's an HTML context if that HTML
context your content has a value if it
finally if it isn't an HTML string and
if some different content we're going to
have to create a string writer and write
the path into another variable do some
other bits and then we're going to sneak
through and make this other source value
to string and then eventually we're
going to use it down here
this just feels buggy all right so let's
let's work on this all right we're going
to do some massive pair programming here
because I'm probably going to need some
help who's written tag helpers anybody
I'm on my own awesome
all right so let's first let's start and
say ok so it looks like I want to really
want to switch not on path but on source
dot value all right and if source dot
value is an HTML string right that's
that first kind of test that's up there
so we're going to do a case
HTML string let's give it a name and it
looks like we really care whether or not
that value is null or not so let's just
let's just be careful here because it
there's this little bit here where I
talked with Damien and David yesterday
as I was working up this demo where if
you look very carefully this is where
like pattern matching as a syntax if you
look carefully past that sources HTML
string okay and then I'm using the Elvis
operator so if it's null this thing is
going to return null
but there's another path where it is an
HTML string and the value for it is null
which Damien said that's evil it should
never happen but I don't like to
introduce bugs so let's just make sure
that doesn't happen so it could be
possible so I'm just going to say it's
HTML string I'm going to say when HTML
string dot value does not equal no
because then I just feel a little bit
better about this case and if that
happens well then I'm just going to say
that path equals HTML string dot value
and that's that's good that takes care
of that part cool well now otherwise it
looks like what I need to check and see
is if I have an eye HTML content and it
looks like that's path HTML content was
B that they used and now I need to do
this bit of code where I'm going to say
and it looks like I'm testing null there
too so let's actually and I don't need
to add that test okay because that
source that value as I HTML content that
will return null if it's not an HTML
content right and we already saw that
with a pattern match it's not going to
match if it's null so I'm not going to
get a null case in here so okay I'm in
good shape there so now I can just copy
this code so I don't really want to
change it and that now goes up under
here we can all set path that's all good
okay what else could it be
so it got an HTML string we've got a
path that HTML content well looks like
the other path that we might have is
we're going to say so I'll value that to
string okay sounds good
I already kind of did that up there
unless it is a string so if past is null
so if value is a string looks like we
had that up here before so we should say
case string s and we're just going to
say path equals s and then we need a
break and now here we're just going to
say this is default string so I feel a
little bit better about the structure of
that code so it could be a string it
could be an HTML string it could be an
HTML content it could be some other
things so then let's go our default and
here I'm going to say path equals source
value question mark dot to strength so
it could still be null if you know
really truly evil evil things happen and
that's the case that kind of falls
through here at the bottom I'm going to
add the question mark that just in case
okay so now I remove close to 20 lines
of code there and I've replaced it with
all close to 20 lines ago but it's so
much cooler now in seriousness when I
look at this code once I get used to the
fact that there's some new syntax here I
find that this the structure of it is
relatively easy and simple okay and as I
was walking through doing this demo and
this is you know after practicing and
analyzing the code and doing it and
thinking about it
I feel in converting it I had to
understand exactly all the paths through
those multiple if-else what could be
what value statements here there are
four distinct cases all of which are
clear all of which are easier to read so
it's one of the things that we want to
do when we're adding new syntax into the
c-sharp language is the developer that
comes after this or damien when he
reviews my pull request should be able
to look at and analyze this code and say
yeah this looks pretty good I think I
like the way this is set up I understand
what it does you may say nasty things
we'll see but it it looks looks
noticeably cleaner we have some really
good stuff that comes in there okay so
do I make those pull requests I'm
actually not going to make them on stage
but I will do them later this afternoon
and the reason is I'm working on a build
on this machine right now that has
slightly newer stuff that kind of breaks
the project system a little bit so I
can't build either one of these projects
completely on this machine and I'd like
to actually build them in and in the
case of no to time run all the tests
before I submit that PR but it should be
done later today so two new bits of
real-world examples of how in both cases
what we think is if I look at the
changes now now I'm not going to up
there that's what you saw but if I look
at the changes I made both here and in
no two time we took code that required a
fair amount of analysis and made it
noticeably simpler it's easier to
analyze and understand all right so
let's finish up with a few more ideas of
where some things might go and some of
the conclusions that we have so what we
really want to do here what really is
going on with pattern matching and
c-sharp 7 right now is taking a very
tentative steps into this world pattern
matching expressions enable a concise
tests and extract syntax so in all cases
we're testing something and extracting
information from it and then we can with
confidence
we can work with that information
knowing that things are set and it's
based on an object's shape as you read
some of the specs one of the terms that
you'll hear c-sharp has a normative type
system it's based on names typically all
of our classes have names our structs
have names and for two objects to be the
same type they have to have the same
class name or struct name as we get into
this idea of patterns and tuples and
stuff we're doing what's called
structural typing two objects have the
same type if their shape is the same and
we'll define shape to say they have the
same properties and that same property
types same property names okay so that's
really what we're doing we're moving a
little bit more away from objects a
little bit a little bit could think it's
dynamic but it really isn't it's all
it's all static typing I know it's the
back of this code just a bit and discuss
a bit about some of the syntax rules so
go back to the small demo and some of
the last rules that are that play into
pattern matching syntax
once again c-sharp trying to be a pit of
success language it's hard to write code
that doesn't work the scope of these
variables when you extract when you test
and extract should be the scope inside
that block underneath it the one
exception to that is an if statement
because of how a couple things work
which is that if I were to make this
modification here the scope of F right
here is valid anywhere in this else
clause so that means it is in scope from
here to here okay now
the scope of AI is anywhere in the
method okay and that's kind of because
to be an if-statement it has to be in
the enclosing block so for any any
pattern match variable its scope is the
block that's enclosing it is however we
also have definite assignment rules so
if I try to use let's say this variable
I if I come down here and I try to do a
right line of I okay it's in scope but I
will get a compiler error that says it's
a use of an unassigned local variable so
it hasn't been assigned the only time
that I is assigned it is definitely
assigned underneath this if so by
combining this test and the extraction
one of the rules that is very important
is you can't miss use those variables in
a place where they didn't get assigned
when the test didn't actually pass okay
other ones just for convenience because
it's just plain time if you heard John
on Wednesday is the case blocks
introduce new scopes in c-sharp seven in
terms of scoping variables so there is
you can squint kind of and see curly
braces around those case blocks so that
that is a distinct different I in those
first two cases okay so what's going to
happen in the future with different
pattern matching well the best place to
find out is if you go to your favorite
searching engine and if you search for
Roslyn pattern matching and github on
any reasonable search engine this page
will be the first page you find it's the
Rosalind repo blob features pattern
slash dot slash features slash which is
why I said search for github Roslyn and
patterns I'm talk about the is
expression talked about our type pattern
constant pattern we already know about
we're testing is the value some of these
are the ones that aren't in the build
right now they're still being talked at
and worked on the VAR pattern more or
less implicitly is there var will match
anything it returns the same type of
what was there so in my expressions here
if I were to do case var oh so I don't
think and then down here was an object
so you can see if I press the dot
it's kind of small like it equals get
hash code get type and two strings so
this particular case matches anything
the VAR pattern it will match whatever
is on the right hand side and it will
return the same thing type the same way
wildcard and positional patterns are
under discussion under work and then we
will have the ability to override
operator is is also in here you will be
able to define an operator ears that can
take an object and return a different
type of object so you can write your own
patterns if you will the rest of these
are pretty similar and finally we will
have I think Katherine went through this
somewhat is destructuring assignment
which i think is more covered under
tuples but if you want to get involved
in these discussions we can you can
participate here for any of the things
that are still working
finally as we finish up and as I take
questions a effective c-sharp the third
edition is available now because it's
available now it covers c-sharp six I'm
working on a second edition of more
effective c-sharp which will cover the
features in c-sharp seven I'm going to
close with a bit of work on what's going
on in the dotnet foundation where the
manage language compilers are part of
that foundation there are a few bits of
dotnet that are now open-source in
public I like the fact that it keeps
taking me longer and longer to work on
this particular slide as I walk through
and watch what happens more and more
things are coming out vs test came out
and was open sourced I think yesterday
was when that announcement was so there
are more different areas that you are
open sourced so in general what do we
think about in terms of open source
investments if you look at the dotnet
framework
everything is very involving asp.net is
if you look at dotnet core well all of
it if you look at xamarin all of it if
you look at the infrastructure
underneath each one of those compilers
language runtime components gotten its
standard in many ways will be open
sourced fully supported cross-platform
Windows Linux OS X visual students
support and so on these are up-to-date I
think we've had even more now which is
really awesome and finally a couple few
links on areas that you can work through
in terms of getting more information
about dinette and so on and make the
survey get swag and finally just how
serious we are about open source even
our swag repos open source if you have
ideas go ahead and submit a PR so we
have a bit of time left
I think the demos went just a little
quicker than I was guessing are there
questions on anything related to pattern
matching in c-sharp
yeah how is it compiled that how is the
VAR case at compile time okay let's just
put it right here
okay so how it is it is a compiler
compile-time what normally happens with
VAR if I assign var to some object by
the types of on the right hand side of
that assignment right so if I look at
the right hand side of this assignment
what that particular pattern is saying
is I want to take that object to test
and I want to assign it to a new
variable obj what is the type of object
to test the static type it's object so
it would be the type of obj object right
so the VAR pattern is in part therefore
syntactic niceness and in part there
because there are patterns where it is
reasonably useful if I want to do
something in the default case I can
assign a variable and do some work with
it okay so var does return the VAR
pattern will return a new label to the
same object so if it is a value type it
will return a new value type with the
same value right but based on the static
type of that object make sense okay
let's get rid of one more there other
questions yes
I missed the last part of that and then
if you use default I think you would get
that let me just put that code back
right so I have R if I remove all these
which is unreachable code looks like
that works i'm surprised that maybe a
bug I may have - I'm going to ask about
that one is that if it's null yeah it
would pass it would work with null I'm
going to ask Neil because I'm not sure
how that's the spec deals with that one
that is a really interesting case it
should do one of the two you're right
but I think it would have to ask I saw
another hand go up that's a good fun
good question yes
okay at the moment I haven't gotten
working with tuples and I don't know if
that's just not in this build or not
specified yet
okay what about generics let's let's
think of what you mean here so let's let
me remove the VAR case up here okay and
let's say I were to write a yeah so we
want a pattern of teeth we're going to
take in a T thing right and now we want
to switch on thing right mm-hmm
so you would want to do something like
is if thing
what's that I mean that would always
pass right because it's generic and if I
did a case of T if we did it with so I'm
going to switch on thing and here if I
did a case T okay that would once again
always pass right okay let's just let's
just have some fun let's just make this
crazy the see if this will compile okay
right
hmm
why dad derives from tea that could be
I'm not sure that that's correct either
because not all teas are tea derived
what's that yeah now it's telling me
that this case is handled by a previous
case which I don't think is correct this
is you guys are smart this is good
that's an actual compiler error it's
using the same analyzer so yeah if I
compile this right now I'm going to get
yeah switch case has already been
handled by a previous case so we can do
things maybe that's another good one I
have to ask about that one too so we
have two good ones too asks one there
and the one about both of our case in
the default case cool what happens if I
change the argue oh so if I were to
change this to object
whoo I want to go back I want see what
happens if we reverse them
okay that makes sense
adding that note so I remember that
later awesome any other questions okay
we're getting close on time and I will
be happy to answer any questions up here
toward the end and again I will post the
slides and the demos sometime later
today also make those two pull requests
with the code we change later today and
[Music]
watch on the github repo for comments
and changes on any of the new pattern
syntax that could be coming soon to a
c-sharp near you thank you very much
[Applause]